well
a local small baseball team
needs your help that such cheers to
cristian that in the afternoons with his new
information from news now in spanish thousands
of dollars put into
training equipment were stolen
belonging to a baseball club in the
northeast of the valley a variety  of
items were stolen based on a
cost of $6,500 the team
has insurance but it won't cover
everything lost so they decided to set up
a golf account for me if you'd like to
help visit news now dotcom for
full details governor skip
sixth  announced a new grant
to help nevada youth with
disabilities this is a
new 5 million dollar program under the name
tots the governor's office says
this is to help children with
special needs and also their
families this  money belongs to the
american rescue plan
the picasso restaurant inside the
pelayo hotel has auctioned more than 110 million  s
of dollars in paintings by the
iconic artist a total of 11 works of art
were sold to the highest bidder who
says that another 12 works will replace the
place these sales left we start
the week with a good day we will all
reach 50 miles per hour in
the south of nevada there is a slight
possibility of rains for the afternoon
beginning at 4 in the afternoon that
could last until midnight
now the temperatures as we can
see are quite pleasant for the
rest of the week cheers to cristian
casseres with his brief information on
news now in spanish good day
[Music]